ja ich habe einen aufreger aus der
schweiz mitgebracht wir alle die denken
ich war sozusagen das hauptquartier der
reinen vernunft gibt auch andere
beispiele im nächsten jahr am ersten
jahren hat 2002 20 tritt ein neues
gesetz in kraft nach diesem gesetz kann
jede person nach der verwendung des 16
das jahr einwohner behörde gehen und
sagt so ich habe jetzt das gefühl ich
sei eine frau wodurch sein mann oder
transgender da können sie ihr geschlecht
aber enden lassen das kostet 75 franken
da kann ich zum beispiel wenn ich ein
mittel der tennisspieler bin als man
kann ich mich zur frau erklären kann
dann ab sofort im tennis
turnieren der frauen mitbrachte nicht
und so fort natürlich über eine liste
der hoch oben bringen ich kann
auch alle möglichen dinge mache mich
zurück verwandt wie will man 70 franken
und das ganze hat so eine weitere
dimension man könnte sagen das ist
einfach der zeitgenössische wahnsinn
aber das hat auch eine sehr auf meinen
sich gefährliche dimensionen sie sehen
in den usa dass es bereits leute gibt
die ihr geschlecht schlechter in den um
straftaten zu begehen das ist auch schon
vorgekommen und mich persönlich
dirigiert am meisten die zu grunde
liegende lüge die das ganze da trägt
nämlich diese unwissenschaftliche
behauptung dass unser geschlecht also
meine geschlechtsorgane sozusagen das
ist einfach so wie meine geschichte ist
eine soziale oder was auch immer eine
einbildung und ich konnte einfach frei
verfügen
es ist eine ganz üble ideologie das ist
unwissenschaftlich das ist ein
biologismus oder wie man immer sagen
möchte und das führt uns eigentlich in
die in die amerikanischen verhältnisse
hinein wo diese art von ideologischem
wahnsinn mittlerweile auch an den
universitäten zum industriestandort
erwogen wird aber leider die schweiz
also hier auch voll dabei
ich weiß gar nicht was ich mir sorgen
aber wir reden doch rätsel oder du wirst
dich und ich liebe das ist wenn ich auch
schon fährt aber bei allem respekt
zwischen 40 tore einen zahl das werden
ganz ganz wenige seien also ich hab mal
für deutschland nachgeguckt deutschland
hat seit 2008 sind beispielsweise ist
das etwas anderes die dritte option
divers kann man im pass eintragen lassen
das haben bis zum 30 september 2020
insgesamt 304 und 90 menschen gemacht
die haben diverse gewählt also lasst die
menschen dort das betrifft doch ganz
ganz wenige menschen wird es doch in der
schweiz betreffen und wenn sie sich
gerne um melden wollen was das
geschlecht betrifft warum stört ich das
denn du bist auch sonst auch freiheits
leben also ich bin entsetzt über diese
fürchterliche oberflächliche betrachtung
irgendwie hatte ich jetzt das er nie
zugetragen sagte genth ich meine du
kannst nicht sagen okay machen ist in
größter not sind aber weiß nur ein power
machen ist nicht so schlimm ich finde
das prinzipiell falsch und es ist meine
tschuldigung es ist richtig es gibt
menschen die eine
merkwürdige identität haben die welt
wird ich sage die die fühlen sich im
falschen körper oder das muss man
akzeptieren dass gibt aber was hier
passiert ist ja was ganz anderes hier
wird eine ideologie eingeflogen die
wirtin die gesetzliche ordnung
hineingebracht in die rechtsordnung und
am schluss sind wir wirklich bei einer
völlig
unwissenschaftlichen sichtweise in dem
jeder nach seinem gefühl einfach
deklarieren kann auch wenn du in deinem
männlichen körper bleibt kannst du dich
als frau könnte mich jetzt regina
komponenten und so einfach dort ab dem
ersten januar in ein neues label
einsteigen und das ist einfach ich finde
das einfach zutiefst unseriös und und
kein mensch einfach so mal eben aus
japan in den usa überhaupt eine sich da
als frau ausgegeben ist der
frauentoilette gegangen hatte eine
vergewaltigt das ist nicht
massenphänomene aber das ist einfach
falsch es ist ausdruck eines falschen
denkens es muss ja vor allem nicht beim
geschlecht aufhören also wenn wir das
die flanke fürs geschlecht aufmachen
stellt sich irgendwann die frage was ist
denn zum beispiel mit dem alter wenn ich
mich als 15-jähriger wir 18 schüler darf
ich dann wählen oder nicht mit welchem
argument sagen sie das gilt beim
geschlecht aber nicht beim alter
geschlecht oder was auch wenn ich sage
ich fühle mich als amerikaner dann mag
das ja sagen die amerikaner werden das
anders sehen aber natürlich machen sie
sozusagen die sagt mit dieser gefühls
hoheit ganz viele flanken auf und da
werden das sind alles einfallstor und
die werden genutzt werden deswegen
glaube ich auch wie herr köppel die
zahlen die bisher vorliegen das müssen
nicht die entscheidenden zahlen seien
sondern das ist ein dass das kann sich
durchaus vergrößern und wie gesagt auf
viele gesellschaftsbereiche hinein sagt
noch eine gute nebenwirkung wir brauchen
keine frauenquote mehr sicher sagen ab
so gut sind da was sie sind zwei frauen
ich glaube da ist gibt es ganz ganz viel
stoff zu diskutieren und das was uns die
schweizer vormachen möglicherweise
findet das hier nachahmung ich finde zb
bemerkenswert dass mittlerweile an
grundschulen ja auch schon so
geschrieben wird in briefen
beispielsweise an eltern zumindest ist
das hier in der hauptstadt so dass man
alle möglichen geschlechter die es noch
neben junge und mädchen gibt auch mit
einbezieht weil man den eindruck hat
möglicherweise gibt es also auch im
alter von sechs und siebenjährigen schon
viele die sich da als divers bezeichnet
das ist eigentlich habe ich etwas wo man
sagen muster wird abseits dessen was wir
in der schweiz jetzt im hauptquartier
der vernunft wie roger köppel es gesagt
hat erleben
eigentlich etwas quasi in die perversion
getrieben die grundschulkinder versuchen
oder den möglichkeiten zu eröffnen zu
sagen bist du eine junge bist du ein
mädchen oder bist du eigentlich divers
das ist eigentlich der gipfel dessen zu
totaler verwirrung und zu allem das ist
aber was helfen könnte was ihr jetzt in
der schweiz nach zum beispiel ich habe
mir schon aus england angeschaut aber es
gibt auch schon professoren in
deutschland die alarm schlagen wenn
kinder zum beispiel schon im jugendalter
mit 16 jahren operiert werden und später
bereuen sie es mit droge wurde ganz
schlimm die wirklich leiden furchtbare
seelische qualen es ist kein phänomen
war so selten auftritt dass man sich
später noch anders überlegt und wenn man
zb 18 einfach anpassen könnte ohne sich
um operieren zu lassen können das auch
ein positiver schritt sein
also ich bin
das was
herr köppel vorgetragenen fast entsetzt
dass dies dass die schweiz wo es zulässt
weil sie was ich ganz ehrlich sagen also
natürlich gibt es die menschen die die
mit ihrem geschlecht den falschen körper
sind kein keine frage die können sich da
gibt es alle möglichkeiten da kommen sie
und bringen das sind alles aber wenn es
dann so einfach so hin und her geht
jetzt bin ich ja mal zwei jahre
eine frau weil jetzt was was ihr in
einem sport vollkommen will und da habe
als man mehr mehr erfolg also dass
konzerne zeigen dass das geht so einfach
drauf meint ist das ganze nicht machen
ein 75 franken ist ja nicht dafür
da also 70 euro
mit mir geht es viel zu weit und da bin
ich echt also für immer so unglaublich
überrascht und schockiert so einfach
geht's und ich bin vierfache fahrt also
ich hab mir oder die kommen jetzt
langsam in der pubertät und ich finde
einfach die ansage des staates dass du
dir einfach ins postbüro gehen kannst 75
franken zahlen konzern ab sofort bin ich
ein mädchen bin ich ein junge das ist ja
auch irgendwo eine kriegserklärung an
diese zum teil ja um die identität von
heranwachsenden die sowieso unsicher
sind und dem du hast du's angesprochen
das ist dann die folge dann pflanzt man
denen diesen gender warnen sehen und
dann haben sie das gefühl nachdem es
sich auch das sind drei haben auch das
gefühl sie seien eher eine frau es gibt
ja auch jungs die im auto habe nach ich
habe auch eine weibliche seite
vielleicht hatte ich aber ich war so
geht das nicht aber haben die trennlinie
zwischen denen die wirklich ja und das
gibt es dass sie haben auch sicherlich
heute die möglichkeiten und die konnten
ja auch früher war es in der schweiz
oder muss das einfach erklären begrünte
man hat zum beispiel gesagt okay sie
wollen eine geschlechtsumwandlung machen
das hat eine gewisse ernsthaftigkeit und
es bekommt sein oder gar charakter und
das ist der punkt also wir sollten hier
eine bayerische schweizerische achse der
wohnung bilden und aus zerrütteten
zurückzuholen die sims werden daher ein
wasserbad
auf das feld am ende ja auch auf die
wiederum zurück die das betreiben also
das hat ja den fall glaube ich in bayern
war das mit der mit der liste bei den
grünen gegeben die also paritätisch
besetzt sein sollte ein mann eine
rettung reicht eine kaufmann und dann
ist ein grüner hingegangen und der hat
auf den frauen platz kandidiert weil er
sagte er fühlt sich als frau oder er
definiert sich als frau so was was
passiert dann in solchen fällen ich weiß
gar nicht wie der fall ausgegangen ist
sie sind vollständig näher dran gewesen
ich weiß seitdem wurden aber nicht
stattgegeben ist das kann ich jetzt
sagen was da bei den als ich weiß dass
ein früherer landtagskollege der
für markus jetzt heißt es weiß nicht ob
das der fall weil sich mit der
grundeinstellung nicht beschäftigt ja es
ist okay ich habe ja vorhin gesagt wenn
jemand glaubt er ist im falschen körper
oder oder er hat der andere
ist es kein mann sondern eine frau oder
oder umgedreht und das wird dann
ärztlich belegt und der wirkliche
problem damit dann kann man das alles
machen unternehmer in einer freien
gesellschaft es ist auch gut so aber ist
einfach so hoppla hopp mit 70 euro oder
75 schweizer franken zu bezahlen und
jetzt bin ich nicht mehr alles ohne
dialyse ich sage euch als habe diese
parlamentarischen debatten miterlebt in
der schweiz und dahinter das stimmt mich
eben auch wenn das motiv wäre bei dem
dass man sagt man möchte leuten helfen
die diese probleme haben das ist nicht
das motiv dahinter stehen einfach
wirklich militante gender ideologie die
unsere gesellschaft ihre
weltanschauung geradezu aufzwingen
worden und mit dem gender stern und mit
diesen ganzen sprach verkürzungen wollen
fenstern wird zu sagen ach ihr ihnen die
in die in die geiselhaft nehmen also ich
lehne das möglich